all right you wanna talk about aoc gang
covert this [ __ ] yeah i guess geez do
you know what aoc is yeah do they talk
about it over there this [ __ ] so not
really over there
yeah why are you so angry
this [ __ ] yo we want her to experience
florida don't we want her to be won over
do we want to have a great time and
realize how important it is
to open the show call everybody else out
down there don't talk about how miami's
not handling covered well don't talk
about how you're vaccinating everybody
who's not vaccinated an idiot
everybody's walking around without a
mask as an idiot and then go party in
miami and all of a sudden you got
nothing to say she always got something
to say oh so that's what she's doing
about this wasn't the same thing about
it wait what happened we've had the
exact same thing in the uk so there's
been a lot of us now though
i don't care about your little british
[ __ ]
get back to this fat tip puerto rican so
what's she doing bro
what'd she do she just went down there
and she did like a drag party and she
got a coke she got colvin she just isn't
saying hey i got coveted yeah she'll
tweet about how when republicans are
calling her out on her hypocrisy there's
some truth to this she's like yo these
guys just want to [ __ ] me so stop making
it these weird this weird relationship
is that true probably some truth to that
can you confirm or deny that probably
some truth to that that's a little bit
true a little bit of truth to that
i would assume
but also you're just being a [ __ ]
hypocrite don't sit here and insult us
and then come live our life on your
[ __ ] vacation and you got all this
smoke for everybody else
you gonna talk smoke to [ __ ] desantis
you got [ __ ] for him oh where you been
the last two weeks where you finna be
[ __ ]
not doing your job quarantining alex
you're puerto rican how do you feel
she's our queen
is she top puerto rican right now nah
she's like number three who's number one
obviously jayla still one bill jlo yeah
come on it's still for sure but she
can't be two
ricky martin
no
oh [ __ ] yeah
david blaine's apparently puerto rican
let's go really yeah oh no
you can't be morally superior and then
go and do the thing that you know you
just can't do that yeah yeah like you
can't that's that's the difference
between comedians and politicians that
no one wants to talk about we can joke
about anything and do whatever we want
because we're not running for office
when a politician is like we need to do
this we need to take it seriously
everyone not doing this as a [ __ ]
idea when they go and do it they've lost
all credibility forever yeah and or if
she even just owned it was like yeah
whatever i guess i was i made a mistake
if she had a thing that she said fine
cnn's not putting out a [ __ ] story
about it at all
but she not tweeting but the thing about
politics is so interesting is like you
only need to
care deeply
about one thing that i care about for me
to support you yeah and i'll forgive
everything else i think that's what
happened with i think that's what
happened with trump and that's what
happens with any of these dudes who like
people have like real passionate fans
like i remember trump was being asked
about the the bible remember they were
like what's your favorite verse and he's
like i like all of them man i like all
them [ __ ]
he said right and and lit christians who
know that he does not read the [ __ ]
bible doesn't know a single verse is
saying but
trump said just enough that they're like
well he agrees with me on a couple
things i care about so i'm gonna rock
with you so it's like almost permission
to be a hypocrite you're allowed as long
as you hold me down for someone else
same thing with sports
right antonio brown you're allowed to do
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] as long as you catch
touchdowns right right as long as you do
something that satisfies me makes me
feel good i don't give a [ __ ] you do it
the rest of your time yeah right yeah so
maybe she's gonna come back her fans are
gonna make it is what it is everybody
gets home regardless the people that
hate her are gonna say the same [ __ ]
they're gonna be like she's a [ __ ]
hypocrite [ __ ] that girl it's like
almost everybody gets satisfied here
anyone who loves her will still love her
anyone who hates her will still hate her
anyone who was in the middle might move
towards
because i was in the middle on her yeah
she's a star she's gonna be [ __ ] but
she's becoming everything that we hoped
she wouldn't i think the problem is
she's too much of a star she too
attractive bernie sanders stayed true to
bernie because i'm a [ __ ] ugly yeah
you know i mean you see hey nobody
offering him the world yeah it's easy
for him to say no he should be in
florida yeah
bernie sanders right move to boca [ __ ]
we don't want to hear about this [ __ ]
yeah
imagine this poor man in vermont right
now
you